après 20 jours de mer enfin les côtes de
la martinique
le message et nantes aura joué les
arlésiennes c'est avec cinq jours de
retard météo oblige que les quatorze
petits moussaillons au mythe y est à
quai en baie de fort-de-france un
équipage aux couleurs et aux accents des
cinq continents
quatorze enfants pour qui cette route
des esclaves a pris des allures de
vacances mais aussi de voyage
initiatique
c'est les vols mais aussi d'en attraper
la barbarie affaires des deux macarons
de ce problème dans l'est deux fois et
l'après midi quand une heure de travail
sur les bases d'un faux ce qui m'a
frappé et poussé les enfants
constitution les enfants la guerre
demain les messages et reprendront la
mer direction new york où ils
rencontreront le secrétaire général de
l'onu élus remettront leur carnet de
bord en martinique deuxième étape du
grand prix plus de droits de l'enfant on
a souqué toute la nuit